here are some reasons why South Korea
will be the only place you'll want to
travel in 2015
Incheon Airport was ranked number one in
the world six times in a row it has a
golf course cultural heritage museum and
an ice skating rink the largest
department store on earth is in Busan
it has 3.1 million square feet of retail
space and some places like Dongdaemun
market stay open past midnight so you
can literally shop till you drop
places love to give you free stuff it's
called Suba zoo the korean pronunciation
of the word service and can range
anywhere from free chicken samples to a
bottle of skin cream mcdonald's delivers
most restaurants do and it doesn't
matter where they'll meet you at the
park on the beach all for no extra
charge plus there is no tipping save
that money for food because there's a
lot you're gonna need you tried kimchi
bulgogi pork belly bibimbap live octopus
chicken and beer whoever called New York
the city that never sleeps has never
been to Seoul
no really club life can be intense
there's no open container law either
feel free to drink your rice wine right
outside the convenience store you bought
it from just remember to let your senior
drink first not a fan of the club life
why not go to a PC BOM often open 24/7
where you can play League of Legends on
the fastest internet in the world
clocking in on average at 24 point 6
megabits per second that's over double
the United States average of eleven
point four megabits so what are you
going to do first in Korea
Wow